-I gained 70 pounds
for this film.
-Did you really?
-I mean, I gained it
like 20 years ago, but...
-You're lactose intolerant!
We can't!
-[ Sings operatic note ]
[ Rasping ] I can't breathe.
-Okay, I trust all of you,
especially you, Gloria Steinem.
You're like, "Heeey, hey."
We have taken on some sponsors,
but some of them are...
pretty terrible sponsors.
Wet Confetti.
No more waiting 'til the end
of the party
to scrape wet confetti
off the floor
because Wet Confetti is wet
from the very beginning.
The party might be over,
but you still got clean up
that Wet Confetti.
I've heard one of the keys to
the success in the longevity
of the Roots over 30 years
is two tour busses.
-Yeah, at least.
-And how does it split up?
Who goes where?
-Cool people go where I go.
My bus is the --
We're the dweeb bus.
-Whack!
And look at this.
I put a frying pan on his chest.
So, I hit him and he goes,
"Nooooo!"
-Don't forget about
Noice Cancelling Headphones.
If there's one thing
we all can't stand
it's when someone says "noice."
Tell the story of how you met
Ariana Grande
when she was 10 years old.
-So her grandma -- her nona --
brought her backstage,
and she said,
"Well, this is
my granddaughter, Ari,
and she also likes to sing."
And I said, "Oh,
that's so sweet."
-And now, new stuff.
These guys are so out of touch
with reality
that when House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi
first announced the impeachment
inquiry in September,
Trump himself argued that it
would actually be good for him.
-I just heard that she'd like
to impeach.
And I mean, if she does that,
they all say that's a positive
for me from the election.
-Oh, do they all say that?
When you say "they," do you mean
your other personalities?
[ As Trump ] Scared Trump
says it's bad,
Sassy Trump says it's good,
and Nerdy Trump says bazinga.
-The single greatest lies ever
foistered...to de-legitimatize.
-My favorite part of Trump's
made-up words
is how he ramps up to them
for effect
with a long pause,
and then gets them wrong.
It's like watching one of those
dudes run up to a pool
and do a cannonball before
realizing it's frozen.
[ Audience ohh's ]
We're also brought to you
tonight
by Just The Juice
Vienna Sausages.
Do you love the taste
of those little sausages
that come in a jar?
Neither do we.
Why we threw them out to bring
you Just the Juice.
[ Audience ohh's ]
-Mmm.
Tastes like a pig
took a salty bath.
No one has ever run into
a parade and gone,
"Oh, good, a parade."
-[ Laughing ] Right.
-There's always part of you
that's like,
"I hate humans."
There was that part where there
was the marching band.
-Yep.
-And marching bands are --
you know, like the precision
and the rehearsal
that goes into --
You know, it's impressive
how a marching band
can take any song
and ruin it.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-Right?
You're always kind of like,
"Wow, I didn't know I could hate
"Uptown Funk" that much.
-I am a terrible procrastinator.
-Yes.
I think a lot of people in our
field are.
-Whoa, yeah!
-Yeah.
-And also at the time,
love to smoke weed.
-Oh, right, right, right.
-Yeah.
So it was kind of like,
"Yeah, I'll definitely do this.
I'll just, like, take
a quick break for one sec."
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-Then, like, eight months pass
and I wake up.
I'm like...[ Gasps ]
-Mouse Pads.
Is your mouse becoming a woman?
Get her Mouse Pads.
[ Music winds down ]
[ Laughter ]
Amberrr!
The world's first vagina museum
is opening in London.
-Men are allowed,
but they don't know what to do
once they get in there.
[ Laughter, applause ]
What -- What -- I mean.
-Just sort of...
Just sort of bang around, right?
[ Laughter ]
The company Glade is currently
selling a scented candle
called Warm Flannel Embrace.
-Warm Flannel Embrace.
Or as lesbians call it --
First Base.
-I'm second-oldest of five.
-Five?!
-Yes.
-Did you guys
all treat each other
with the same respect
that those kids were treated
with on the film set?
-We did not.
-Yeah, yeah.
Worst household ever.
-Really?
-Yes. Yes.
Think -- Think "Animal House."
-Okay, yeah.
-On any given day, you could get
your ass kicked.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
And finally,
Family-Sized Toilets.
[ Laughter ]
Are you tired of everyone
in your house
going to the bathroom
separately?
With this massive,
12-foot-wide toilet,
there's enough room for everyone
in your family,
even grandma.
Finally, going to the bathroom
is an activity
the whole family can do
together.
Family-Sized Toilets!
Because family
is number one and...
number two.